écrin de verdure qui entoure le château
royal commence déjà à donner des signes
de fatigue les précieux jardins du
château d'amboise n'échappe pas aux
restrictions d'arrosage et bien nous
avons décidé du fait de la grande
sécheresse de ces biens de sacrifier
cette partie du couvert végétal de
domaine c'est la partie la plus
importante c'est par là que nous devons
commencer les économies d'eau massif et
plantes qui structurent ce jardin
remarquable de deux hectares sont
arrosés avec parcimonie c'est un bien
végétale de plusieurs années la pelouse
c'est navrant mais c'est pas grave
sachant que c'est de la grameen et à son
herbe donc ça va certes ça l'avenir mais
dans des clapiers à revenir et que du
coup les conditions seront meilleures
pour arroser on verra aux rats et l'air
d'avoir devenir verte comme à l'été
avant en rive droite du fleuve royal à
une dizaine de kilomètres de là le
potager conservatoire du château de
valmer est en souffrance les tomates
elle n'arrive plus à former des fruits à
partir du moment où la température
dépasse 30 degrés donc la fleur 'sauver'
mais le pollen est incapables de
féconder et donc ça fait pas de tomates
voilà on attend que les autres mûrissent
mais celle là cette fournée l'a
probablement ne va pas produire de
thonon pourtant conçu avec un
goutte-à-goutte programmer la nuit
l'adaptation au manque d'eau est une
rude épreuve
c'est une année comme on n'a jamais eu
je pense que moi ça fait cinquante ans
que je suis dans ce jardin j'ai jamais
vu ça on a un mélange de 1976 et de 2003
pour faire simple à dire qu'on a la foi
de la sécheresse et de la canicule le
niveau du puits est un sujet de
vigilance quotidienne pas d'eau pas de
jardin